i really dug this you both did fantastic
work in it
uh before i jump into talking about
specifics uh all the interviews i've
been doing recently i've been asking uh
two sort of softball fun questions what
tv series would you love to guest star
on
what am i watching at the moment i
haven't been watching much
at the moment at all actually uh okay
so i i finished watching um uh
sex education too so i'm just gonna say
that
i think it's a great show i really
enjoyed the
few seasons of stranger things i like
the 80s
homage to old school spielberg so let's
let's say that
uh the other question is uh what movie
do you think you've seen the most
um empire strikes back i'd say
watched it lots as a child um i
think this is it's a really this is a
really obscure one
it's called let me get the name right
bmx bandits which is an australian film
uh with a very young nicole kidman but i
got it out so many times
at the video store that they just gave
it to me
yeah i got out so many times when i was
a kid like just have it no one else is
getting this bill
just take it so i'd say being at bandits
yeah
uh i have so many follow-up questions
but i'm gonna jump into why i didn't
talk to you guys today
um one of the things that i really dug
about this series
is that there are no quote-unquote
villains it's not like either of your
characters are out to get her
there's nobody trying to you know squash
her dreams or
um it's basically she's trying to
overcome herself
uh can you sort of talk about the fact
that that there are no villains in this
series
yeah no i think that's a really
interesting point actually that i hadn't
even thought about
um uh and i think you kind of answered
it yourself already that
she's battling her own enemies her own
demons
and um i think that's what's lovely
about it i think that's what
regardless of whether you like chess or
not uh you'll get away from it
is that you everyone battles their own
demons and everyone
struggles with themselves the most more
than anyone else
um and that that's the hardest one to
combat
so i mean it's it's also yeah
chess is a world where you have an
opponent you that is your enemy
um that's the person you're supposed to
tackle and um
and deal with at the time but the
biggest person you have to deal with
is is yourself and how you play the game
and
and and all the psychological psychology
that goes along with that
um so i think that i think that's why it
will um
hit home for a lot of people that don't
necessarily
love or know anything about chess
yeah i think yesterday that's a really
interesting question i think um
it was interesting talking to lots of uh
chess players
uh and how they hate to lose
um and so the
intensity and the rivalry between these
chess players is
is quite full-on i remember watching a
few games and you literally
some games you're watching the opponent
have a nervous breakdown because they're
losing it really is the stakes are that
high
um and i think that's a really
interesting idea which is
the enemy or the sort of the the
the menace in this uh series is is beth
herself um which i think is very very
true to what
what scott's written and what the
original walter teves book
um was about as well uh what's
interesting is
um the chess sequences in the in the
series
are you know they're the action scenes
of
of this series and um normally with an
action set piece you
are learning all these fight moves and a
sword or whatever it may be
but in this it's about your hands and
how you're going to move the pieces
um can you sort of talk about like
prepping
chess sequences like an action scene a
very interesting way of looking at it
yeah
i mean you know when you when you've had
a combat scene with swords or with guns
or
or um or dance choreography it i mean
chess
is a choreography it's uh it's a dance
between two players and
um we had to work very hard on learning
how to move these pieces
correctly there's a there's a correct
way to move chess pieces
weirdly enough which i i didn't realize
but you move it but
how you move those pieces is is a kind
of uh like a poker game a giveaway
or a telltale sign to the opponent of
how confident you are within the game
so even if you're not and even if you're
bluffing you have to move those pieces
to
suggest that you're in theory in this
place but it's because you're actually
trying to hide something you're doing on
the other whole side of the board and
hoping that they don't realize that
which is fascinating it's not what we
had to really deal with but it was um
we just had to memorize and learn how to
how to play the certain games for the
certain scenes but
speaking to the people who who taught us
how to play with conviction
and um and how to look like we are
actually champions um
they were saying that's that's that's
the most important thing whether whether
your game is
is going well or not it's about
trying to hide that and show the other
person that you have
um authority with with just little
pieces of wood that you move around the
board i mean
there's something really quite beautiful
about it early on scott
uh frank the director writer said uh try
and find a chess player who you
who you want to steal their sort of i
don't know their little eccentricities
the little details how they
prep the pieces how they move the pieces
and so that was very interesting in
terms of
every single uh player that i've i've
seen in terms of research moves it moves
the pieces in a slightly different way
some slide across the board some sort of
lift it up and slam it down
some use the pieces to to hit the clock
which is a bit
a bit arrogant um so all of these
little things tell stories um and that
was the uh
the the accumulation of those details is
what i think our work
was as actors to try and to try and
implicate in our in our characters
the production design uh the
cinematography costumes there's like no
weak link in the chain
uh for both of you as actors uh can you
talk about when you step on set and
there's just so much
practically there how that enables you
uh as an actor to just deliver even you
know
just a great performance for me that's a
big big big big part of it
um i've never really kind of had any
kind of confidence in what i'm doing
until i put a costume on really
when you when you feel when you put that
when you put the character's shoes on
for the first time that's the first time
you feel
how they are grounded in the ground you
know how how they might walk
when you when you when you have a
costume when it changes how you move and
the weight that it carries
it it for me that's that's when i feel
the most
like i'm in character and we were very
lucky with
having some i mean most of them were
real
uh real locations that we used there was
some studio work with the studio
the the the the the sets that they built
were
phenomenal and beautiful and felt like
my home where i live as best as benny
benny's home
in new york was um his little basement
flat was a complete studio set but it
felt
like you're in new york i mean maybe
it's just maybe even smelt like in new
york
um and so that that that immersion into
that world helps hugely dramatically
with with
grounding yourself and placing yourself
in the surrounding that you are
supposedly meant to be
in um and i think that's one of the
biggest tools
a big moment i think in terms of when
you do all the work and you step onto
set that's the that's the moment where
you go okay i can forget about all the
work now everything is here for me to
use
um and we were lucky in that the sets
were that good that you really
could forget about all the chess work
and the um
and the other bits and pieces that you
sort of prepped you could just forget
about it and just be involved in the
scene
which is always the gift of going on to
those very sort of detailed um
evocative sets thank you so much i'm out
of time
you guys enjoy the rest of your speed
dating congrats on the series
thank you so much